More than 60 percent of the housing stock in Germany
was built before 1949, so it's
really old and that's why you then have
a renovation backlog and
then new markets open up, which you
probably don't all work on in the same way
as the classic DIY store
came into being, you buy an item
on the shelf the customer comes
out and takes away
the topics you mentioned,
whether that’s making a home smarter,
whether that’s the photovoltaic system
on the roof, whether that’s somehow the
irrigation system for your garden,
these are all things that a  are a bit more
complex and are no longer just
a product but already a
product and a product and an
implementation, so rather think about solutions
and that is definitely the
growth area that we see because
actually the market in the hardware store
is speaking for Germany
20 billion euros, but if you
look at our customers' homes and gardens, the market is 10 times as big,
200 billion, hey, at OMR we've
never talked about hardware stores, but
you can buy things there in particular to
prepare for the
end of the world or you  can
earn money with hardware stores so dear
preppers and dear friends of business
now the new CEO of Obi is coming here in the
podcast on, let's go moin Sebastian moin
Philipp it was one you have
n't been here from Obi that long no that
was I've only been since the end  September that's
why it's actually still quite fresh
but you're not fresh anymore you've been there for
quite a while that's true
I've been there for over 10 years that
's actually an interesting
story that I then developed from the inside out,
so to speak, since the
beginning of 2012  I started at OBI
and before that I had to briefly explain something to everyone.
You studied classically in Münster, did a
doctorate, then
did consulting and then it's often a
way because you don't where you then go into some kind of
classic digital firm in some kind of
investment banking or something else, but
then you are  after the consultation and
ended up at the hardware store, yes, I
studied economics, the rest is correct,
so yes, it depends, but I think
what was classic again,
if you don’t
end up in investment banking with me after the
consultation, then you at least end up in
corporate development and that  I
also did it at OBI, so I
started in cockpit development without
employees, that was very
interesting, I'm the head of
corporate development, but I was the head
of myself, I started on my own and
that was really good in retrospect, because
I  then I was able to really understand Obi
and listen that didn't
immediately have a responsibility and didn't
have a team and I was able to
listen and understand it one can
assume that everyone in Germany
knows Obi yes one can assume that
we have a brand awareness of  95%
we are already one of the best-known
brands and erm I would assume
everyone knows Obi and I would almost
say most of them have been
in the hobby at some point how many
markets there are we have 650 markets in
ten countries in Germany 350 that
about 50% of the turnover is
also via Germany, so it
is true in Germany in particular, but also in the
other countries there are significantly smaller and
fewer do-it-yourself people than the
Germans and that is why we are
particularly well known in Germany, it
is also a relatively large one
Company so tell us briefly we have a turnover of over 8
billion we have
over 40,000 employees in the stores
and at the head office we are active in ten
countries and yes, above all, over 50
years old I think it is
still worth mentioning how many
business models there are  deals
a lot with new business models she has
time now is often getting
shorter and yes that's why we 19
2022 21 we had
Obi's 50th birthday
we have to come to where come Obi
Herbert founded Manfred Maus
that was founded with Mr. Lux and
erm Manfred Maus for many,
many years, then he founded them or the
company since 1970 and yes,
that actually
made them big for the first 30 years and at
some point sold them and then, err,
brought in Tengelmann and  85 and
then you became the main shareholder,
but we still have a
second shareholder next to Tengelmann,
the Luke family and the Luke group of companies,
and they are also
the Lukes who also come to Essen, where I
come from, the cars in parts, yes,
okay, there were  Mercedes or something like that,
I think, okay, okay,
entrepreneurial family, yes, in any case,
entrepreneurial is not a
small meal, just a Obi, that would be
if it were on the stock exchange, probably in the
badger,
no, we will not, er,
be for that, I think it is then  also
evaluation of more stationary in the trade
is there I don't think there was there
then in the DAX with but
yes again something to understand what is
an asset value so what do you want to say
is there or so yes we have
the Hornbach one  our competitor
is on the stock exchange if he
looks at the market capitalization
then it's I don't have the current
figures but I think it's something
around 1.34 billion it's the
Hornbach valuation we're we're
bigger than Hornbach with  Obi
yes, but it will then play out in you of the magnitude,
why do you want to
get it back then, so
ten years ago you were already worried
that the
hardware store model might have to be modified somehow
or something like that, no, that was your job back
then when I was me  As I said, I
did the cockpit development in the classic way. That was to report directly to the
CEO. He then had a small
strategy unit for yes, for all
kinds of questions
from our from our
countries from our headquarters and that
was a classic strategy job
that you where my profile fitted well
with the training and the questions that
only came up over time
like how does the customer actually change
the requirements that we as  as
Obi yes what requirements we as if
we have that we remain relevant for our customers
only
became strong when I was
there then I still know we started talking
about such market shares and
sales in the market and
Then Amazon kept
appearing at the top of the rankings and we just made
up our minds that it overtook you in
sales for a pure hardware store range
and you
could see that and that was
the moment when you started  to
say okay what does that mean for
us now in the long term and what so
tell me a little bit you
started
working years ago on making the saying Obi somehow more
digital so really
in the starting shot  me
in my team we then
started in 2017 we founded Obi Obi next
that was the answer that
we said okay we have to
think stationary thought retail
find answers from the Rhine how we stay close to the customer
and then decided
that  we are building a new unit with Obi next,
but
we also deliberately placed them next to Obi, we
then moved to Cologne with the
unit to have access to
other talents there and also to
a certain extent with some things,
yes  also to create the degrees of freedom
to do things differently from the
way of working, but also technologically, so
we also
built new things technologically
and did not
add to the existing technology, so to speak, and also from the way of working,
so we were typical Spotify videos at the time
It all started at the time, how do
they work and then we
also looked at such topics and then
said okay if we want to expand modern products from the
customer then we have to
build them on the green field and
have them built differently than in the past, but that’s above all  Things like
digital products or, to put it
simply, the um hey
Obi app was created, that's um that's the
core product with which we said we
actually want to accompany the customer
in his home on his in his
journey and um we want to
stay close to him  and that was the
iconic product that we used at the time then
the idea came up and it's
live now what
can you do so a few
examples
yes you can with the app our goal back
then was actually
to remain the constant companion of our customers
and that means we can
do both classic things and
of course shopping, but what you can do and that's that's it,
we learned a lot is
that you can do digital advice,
so you can do it no matter where you are, you
can in your garden  Stand by and
get an OBI consultant to go home
digitally and you can show him your terrace
and say listen, I want to
build a terrace here, we are the
soil conditions, how do I approach
a project like this, what do I need for it,
then you can go to the OBI store afterwards
plan the terrace and then he puts it
back in your app after the planning
and then you can find it there again, so
we stay tuned to the customer, so to speak, we
have care plans, that means if he
somehow says afterwards I
somehow want my um always green lawn
or  I love English lawns do
n't know how to get there it
still looks like a field today then he gives you
care tips and uh said per month what
you have to do and that's a different topic
but we also have topics in there we
have an insta navigator like that  a
typical question when you come to the hardware store
is either where is the employee
or where is the product you are
usually looking for? 10,000
square meters, such an OBI store has an
average of 40,000 items, so you have
a few questions if the
you come in and then typically
you ask the employees as I said you
often can’t find them and that’s why
we now have an insta navigator in the hey Obi app you
can then enter your product search
and then it navigates you individually
in the market where  is now my yes my
adhesive tape both that so how often has
the app already been installed we
now have over 4 million customers in
the app and uh we have that now in the
last two and a half years we have
reached over 4 million but it
should be like that  these typical
metrics like mansley active daily
action and stuff like that yes we have over
50% active customers
a month or so we then uh yes
I think we bought a
year is active with us and and
usage how often you then the the
on  In any case, I don't know if
every 12 months or monthly,
I think more like 12 once a year who
opened the app and used it
and interacted okay and the
whole thing comes out
of the idea a bit how can you
Distinguishing from Amazon has been a big
question for many for years and
one argument is always about
services and things that just do
n’t always work like that, they kind of have
the huge shop and the products and
sometimes good prices, but you say
okay  Service Layer Obi does that
better, absolutely, so I think that
's actually the question that was asked at the beginning
like you said, or that's
how it started seven eight years ago
when we then
saw the effect Amazon
had on it  and
there is I think I would
prefer to start the whole thing
at home and the gardens our
customers are a totally exciting field
because that’s where the preoccupation begins
well before the purchase so favorite
example that I’m in the  The context
always do is stay with
the terrace until the customer
buys a terrace tile, it takes
three months before he
has been involved with the project and that's exactly where
we want to start because DIY
home and garden puts the customer
ahead of many  Questions, problems and
challenges, be it what
skills do I have,
can I do it at home at all, can I
do it myself, do I need someone
else, what does my budget allow, what is
the construction like and we can
deliver significantly more added value than you can now
He might be able to deliver to Amazon,
but I do
n't think it's a priority because it's
about competence, it's about knowledge,
and that's where our
employees play a big role because we
have an incredible number of competent
employees, it's just
always the challenge  knowing where
is exactly the right one that we
need right now and that's why we also switched
the employees behind it in the app, so to speak,
as I just
said with the video telephony and
we also know that the
employee in Markt in is here  Kamp-Lintfort is
extremely familiar with
terraces and then we
take care of it and store it and then we can
assign the customer problem to him,
even if the customer is in Hamburg right now
and that is of course
a big differentiation because we are there
just then the quality of advice and
ignorance Questions
Implementation difficulties are
hardware store topics are one of the most
googled topics if you
deal with it all these problems
and challenges from customers who are
just immense is the mold yes no is
the wall crooked how do I get it
right now so there is yes  so many
questions but you've
decided you really want to
solve the content yourself about
people that's nothing to start with that
generates sales, so
in the end it's speculation that this will
sometimes lead to them buying more from
you, yes  exactly so it's uh it's the it's
about the customer it's
about us understanding the customer that
we understand the customer
and
deliver more values ​​to them and how you give them more points of contact with us
and we then end up with the
customers  also bind more to us and can
we do that so is the
volume measuring yes we can measure that we have I
remember when I started at OBI
we said yes how
often did customers buy one in the hardware store yes
we know from GfK  We
did a study once a year, the purchase between
5 and seven times a year and YES, but
that's a little bit for the fact that
we have access to the customer what we
know about it, so that you
have to ask GfK now we have over
our 4 million customers in the app
I can tell you that we
have contact with customers 50 times a
year on average now opens an e-mail or
does something in the app or sends a
request to the consultant so we
now know that we  50 interactions
clearly mean that the frequency of purchases is
now not automatic from 50 purchases that are
not made 50 times, but then they inform
themselves, plans and so on, but we
create the added value for them,
understand them so well that we will then
hopefully provide them with better purchase
support and  that's
the bet, as you called it, which
we then make, and we'll know whether you've
grown quite strongly in the last few years, probably
during the pandemic, no, during the
pandemic we grew 20 20 21 strongly,
but otherwise you're in such
a saturated market as
Before that, we had Germany or Austria, and
before that we always had growth rates
of two or three percentage points. It's
different in Eastern Europe, there are
growth rates, there's even more, so
if you take Hungary like that, the
gross domestic product will grow by 20% and then
grow accordingly  the
sales from us with the people are also increasing
in income and investing in their
home, so that’s why we are on average across the
whole of Obi in the
middle single-digit range on
the entire group of pandemic
special situations 20% or something like that or 30
or the  group yes that was over 10% it
was because the people
all actually
built at home and so the people
had to stayed at home they
built something they finally had
time the people didn't
go on vacation spent vacation at home
people have remodeled their home office
and home, so I
think that's the beauty of our
for every phase of life is
actually also reflected in your home
and that's why we also believe as one of
our cures is my home is my
castle and that's where it comes from  We get a lot of
emotional needs from customers, which is
why we take many such phases
with us somehow quite well. What does
a typical German spend a year at
OBI, in the hardware store if you can
believe the GRP pay here,
there are
euros a year  and that's exactly
the trick now, how much of it does Obi
spend and I can tell you if I
'd taken the old numbers
he shops six times a year because they're
in the average tree between 35
between 30 and 40 € you're somewhere  at around
250 €.
with our knowledge, of course, more precisely
and we also know that it was more like
1200 € more that customers spend with us
and that is also
part of customer loyalty
customer lifetime we
already see there and then we also see that
customers who  just buy stationary and online
and interact even more in the app
then in turn
spend more so the customers who had more than 50
contacts I had just
said the average 50 contacts
then buy accordingly more
at OBI than those who have fewer than 20
contacts  So then we see that they
buy online and in stores,
but significantly more in stores I would have
thought that somehow the
main argument for DIY stores
is often how close summer is, too,
so that’s why Obi is also in
Germany, we have 350 stores, we
have them  most markets and that's
why we're also the best-known
brand and erm also the biggest turnover
because proximity
is very important there and that means
you can't fight it against the difference and
hagebaumarkt comes set
up a branch right next to you then that's stupid
It's always stupid, yes, but it happens, but it
happens quickly, yes, now
the momentum is
a bit less in Germany, we have
many DIY stores and also many
different DIY stores, so the
next momentum has become a little less,
but in other countries it's
still quite higher  how it used to
be with the bakery they say ok there
is a hardware store or a bakery that
is doing well there is a good one
next to you so they don't do so badly
yes there is also um it's
generally interesting I
keep stumbling across new hardware stores
Chains that sometimes only have five or
ten or that's it, so in addition to the
big players there's also
a really relatively deep market and
regional chains or local chains
are after that and it's the spotlight,
it's still very fragmented in
Germany that's the same  it's quite
a difference to other countries, so
if you look at France,
look at England, uh, the
markets are much more concentrated, that
's now even on the big chains,
but you still have
a lot of smaller local players because they're just
around  on the subject of building materials,
the transport of the transport of
articles is expensive when you look at goods and
things like that, that’s why there
are also local chances of survival for you, some of the markets
belong to you and some of the markets belong to
franchise partners, no, that’s how we are
we grew up back then it was
part of this growth strategy that he was
then
able to grow faster with less investment because local
entrepreneurship was acquired, so to speak,
and think the
franchise partner is good if you now
make all these additional online offers, so to speak, because that costs sales in case of
doubt  well, at the beginning
they weren't that good exactly from the
argument that you mentioned, I think
our fanshos partners have now
also understood that 50% of our
customers are with us at obi.de before they go into the market
and are
busy  with the item is
available what do i need as i
said they are not like
a supermarket or say i
just go there and think about it while shopping
i don't even want to eat
or need there are many that's enough with
us in the  It's a bit
more complicated and difficult at the hardware store, you
either forgot how big the
measurements were at home and so you always have a
bit of preparation and that's why
we have this 50% share and
the fanshos partners also benefit from it, so that's
why I think first of all
glad that we are now also digitally
the most-visited website you
have around at home in the garden only Ikea
in front of us the interest
yes okay but Pinterest but I am
not the yes that that that
certainly so they will be
even more looking for the  are just good
for inspiration, so especially when he
wants to say how how do I want what what
we have ideas I'm sure that's
behind that too, that's exactly where we see it
more on customer groups that I
just younger uh then
actually inform others about Pinterest
then take er actually find out more
in the hardware store
older younger ones are then on
Pinterest but then the
fanshos partners also understood that
it is also necessary for them and in
the future we will also err
have to integrate them even better in  this
whole digital world that we create
but hey obi-app they all also
err eagerly we've built a consulting center
that's technology where we
also want to integrate our employees into this digital world
so that they what I
told you before when your planning
makes of  the terrace that this
information also appears in the app afterwards,
we have also created the technology for the
employees in the stores
so that they can also do
the video diaconia from their workplace in the store
and
we have also made this technology available to the franchise partners
so that those there are
also benefiting from all these efforts have
you ever considered
buying content pages yourself, so I
think I've observed it myself over the
last year
or even talked about the fact that
American companies sometimes then or
examples like this music division Thomann
go there and say we buy
content websites ourselves or
editorial offices that do the same thing so
that was what you thought about yes well
we also built our own um
content site I’m starting I’m just
a bit slower because I
just thought about what it's called but
we've created a lot of content
and that also increases our
SEO traffic share and
also makes our visibility good for
certain topics that's really important what
you say with the content what we still do  have
done is we have
partnerships
my Homburg for a long time
also accompanied as a partner we
also have with my beautiful garden so we
have different cooperations
then with with publishers also just
problem could you live somehow
nicer then buy magazine
or  something like that, I'd be happy to pass it on
again, that we'll
check it again if the prices fall, whether we
can then make a deal,
maybe even contacts, so if
you say okay, nicer living or something,
houses are also called a
magazine, I thought  now absolutely so
the absolutely so this content
topic is totally relevant how we
occupy these topics and these people
inform themselves that is absolutely central for us so
a magazine like this gives you
a lot of appetite
I would still say that we
still spend a relatively large amount
Google can't complain, but
as I said, we also have a
lot of direct traffic because whether we
're known and also SEO, so we
're already impaid there, that's less
than less than 25%.  okay and then when
Peter does he has, above all,
which Google campaign not now, so
that you two are not sports sponsoring
or who is TV advertising or something like that,
nee, above all, uh, Google,
but we have
sponsoring, do it a little bit, we used to have it
once sponsored the World Cup 2006
was Obi was Obi sponsor, we
then completely stopped that even if
sport and Obi actually
go together quite well and
yes, the
iconic beaver, I
should know that the television always recognizes it,
or yes, you know it from the television
advertising absolutely  and you wo
n't miss it there in the future that
's an absolutely ionic feature of
our brand there's also one in every
OBI store, by the way, every OBI store has a
beaver costume, so someone can always
stand in there and make our customers
happy, so there
's still television advertising  Yes, absolutely
TV advertising is a topic that we have
always done and will
continue to be part of our media mix in the future,
but of course also otherwise.
Moving images in all the other
streaming providers is actually
quite funny because there are many companies that
have such a long heritage  we now Obi
we then at some point changed their
testimonial
mascots or their advertising figures
so I don’t know earlier
or were there somehow Uncle Dittmeyer
and
so many other
somehow chronic advertising
ideas and actually they were all
discontinued and now there is only
somehow I think from  recently
the gentleman told the group at Trigema
there is still I heard the episode
with the monkey exactly
but I don't think
it's smart enough to
say goodbye to them we also
slowed down the beaver a bit for a while
but when we have
examined our brand values ​​again and have dealt with the
brand and
we have done
that very intensively in the last six months, yes I have done that very
intensively, then Obi has the
three letters orange and the beaver and
at the end if you with the beaver
can communicate so much more and faster
than with a lot of text and also the
whole thing with the basic emotional
mood that the Obi brand
resonates with, namely likeable, more
approachable, but also a bit of the
doer mentality then that’s
perfect as the one, so that’s why we will
and don't see the Obi Bieber
more than less
let's talk a little bit about these
franchise partners because I
think we've actually
discussed that far too seldom
tell your biggest franchise partner
how many markets it has the biggest
fanshos partner has 15 markets and  it is
then probably or
logically for him a million
business no for him it is a million
business yes so you can also if
you then operate OBI market or if
you continue now you can also
become a millionaire
yes then there if you have a good one  If you
have a location and run it well, you can
also get rich with it, so what
makes sense, so an
average market has a
turnover of 10 million euros and then
a million hangers-on or something like that in
very good markets, uh, and our
fanshos partners have a few
of them there  who make very good stores
and they are simply local
entrepreneurs you shouldn’t
underestimate that I mean that’s 10
million in sales and a typical store
is 800,000 square meters has
an average of 60 employees that
’s not a branch
like you can’t call other retailers
but it was  just
put in an assortment like this 500 square meters
have a cash register and good things so the
60 employees in incoming goods clear up a
bit of his whole lot also on
consulting business and on
stock there is also capital
that there is that you
have to manage properly and that’s why these are local
entrepreneurs  definitely also a great
innovative power and also a motor of
such an entrepreneurial development
because your plan is to have more of it
or for a long time
we didn’t have any more so the
last 20 years have not
grown there with franchising but in
our future strategy
Franchise is an integral part of it because I
strongly believe that we can achieve our goals
that we have with growth ambitions
better with partners than doing everything alone,
so I think the world has
become so complicated out there, that's why
we are actively entering into partnerships  and
franchise partner is what we
actually learned from the beginning
what's in Obi's DNA and that's
why we'll
stick to it very strongly, but if
someone at his hardware store is listening,
I'd be up for it then he can  I'd be
happy to get in touch but probably
somewhere in Eastern Europe than in Germany,
yes, but also in Germany, I
said that's a very fragmented,
very fragmented market and
if we multiply them a few more of
the fragments under Obi then that
's it too
Hamburg didn't start off so badly nepombüttel
was the first market yes in 1970 and
what was the way to
austriana Wermelskirchen
yes we now have churches is the
do-it-yourself capital that's yes
you always underestimate it when you
get that  who will also name a lot
is at Cologne that is located near Cologne
Bergisches Land between Cologne and
Dortmund on the A1 and there are
also a whole lot of
manufacturers of
hand tools because they come from the
Wermelskirchen Remscheid
Solingen area from this from this area
and sat there  also back then the
tool manufacturer emilux and that was
the guck founder of Mr. Maus and
erm that is the origin of why
it is based in Wermelskirchen which
is actually the most frequently sold
product at OBI so what was most
carried out
that will definitely also
be moving boxes  but also topics
such as cobblestones, of which you
need a lot and many individual items
and now you don't have the tens of thousands to choose from,
so yes,
cobblestones probably okay okay
moving box even if there aren't that many
different sizes he
actually made a lot of your own brands
by now, well  a mark
makes 30% of the turnover that's
a
big part of
our business and um yes it will be is it
a bit like
Amazon looks at what's going well and then
if that's particularly attractive then
you build something of your own  together and
that you can endure this mobile phone yes, but
of course it is now that the
hardware store range is not as
dynamic as you get other ranges now,
for example with clothes, there
were trends then, but that is
more of a constant range where you
actually  even if you
know the margins where you know what
brands are available or where there are
hardly any brands there are not that
many well-known brands in the hardware store
segment and that’s why it’s more of a
long-term thing at which points
you then choose for  Own brands
usually decide in addition to the
brand or where there are no brands, you also
want to occupy some price entry points what what are there for this?  we
also have our own brands for colors
accessories so actually quite so very very
broadly through the range where we
also offer our own brands also for
what is the name of the electric machine
looks drill is it actually the same for you
as it is for me from the foodstuffs from time to
time so rumored that  because then
the hardcore buyer says somehow
okay love, I don't know Nutella or
rather Haribo or whatever it is,
unfortunately we have to lower the price
again and we have to
lower it again and so the really hard rounds
of negotiations are also the case with you
that he  with you there too, that you also have
purchasing colleagues, then
somehow you always really fight the toughest
battles there, so always listen to
any suppliers and and and
and so always and I'm not there
myself I haven't
conducted any purchasing negotiations but basically
it's like that  we
actually want to approach this whole issue
as a partnership, so
it's just such a thing, the subject of
cultural
change is something we're also concerned
with at OBI for over 50 years and you
bring a few
different things with you, just like
we do ours
We also want to enable customers, as I just
said, many of the topics and goals
that we are planning we want to
achieve in partnership in the future, whether with franchise partners or with other partners,
and that's actually how I imagine
the cooperation with the suppliers
but of course it's like that if if
the prices go up then let's say no the
prices can't go up, otherwise
the prices for our customers will go up
and of course there's also a
tension that I think is quite
normal in business as long as you do it
fairly and and and transparently  and
somehow leads to a rational basis,
that's part of the feeling when
you go to your website, there
are already so many very modern
elements on it, so the communications,
this whole service idea, but there
are also, for example, I
remembered completely different brands like shops  So
if you then get a bit thrilled then
you click on any of
your brands and they have
their own shops under Obi, so to speak, so then you can have
any lights or lamps or
something normal from a manufacturer separately.
Age yes,
we did that because we are
Our goal is not to
expand our private label business in any way,
we just want to
give our brands the space
to present themselves to our customers, so that's how
we see our role. We have a
platform, yes, we have it, we have
access to customers  the
customers understand better and better I told you
on the 4 million customers we understand
the customers very well and
we are happy to share this knowledge with our
suppliers that they can make even better
product ranges and offers for our
customers and we
also said on  On our
website we are also happy to offer you the
opportunity to open the brand shop, so to speak,
so that your range can be
perceived more strongly in your brand. That costs the
customer what it costs if they take a brand shot like this.
That is part of
our Obi  Media Group that's our
retimedia business that we
started four years ago with, among other things,
precisely such brand shops and
they are also very satisfied there, so if the
customer then searches for a brand or then
moves to markenshot, then of course you've got
something out of it  from the
pure product comparability and
you can also play your brand better
and that is
also quite interesting for some of our suppliers it
is the largest offer that makes in the retail
media area so brand shops
or there are others at the moment yes um
but here we are  of course also
in the expansion of this business and there can
also be other
marketing-related things,
such as which articles do you then play
out in the search algorithm or also our
entire customer insights that is
also incredibly exciting for manufacturers who
give a relatively large amount of money from
market research  and we can
actually say exactly
that and the customers have a boschenk
Kärcher or something else at home and
therefore in the here and there interest or
life so and so or buy that and the
other articles or there you can
run the campaign for the and  and and and
book these are of course all
possibilities that we
are still expanding but we also have to do them even
better technologically, so to speak more
automatable Know
your way I mean
now you are 44 is not that old yet
so I am  soon uh but you
are now Stefan Obi so I mean it
started anyway what was
your secrets or magic source there
making a career about it so how will there be a
mentor or just somehow what
was the way then because that
yes  Well, I think you
always have to be a bit lucky to be in the right
place at the right time. I think I
listened carefully at the beginning and tried to
understand Obi well, and then at
some point, like
a lot of people, I became passionate  at OBI the
passion grabbed you and then
at some point you have a feeling hey uh
actually more is possible here and
then this this yes this this
mission that we
have actually written into the strategy we enable Youtube
create your home in  Garden die
then prompted me to cancel and that
is actually the part of this
conversation that we had now, there is
actually a lot more possible than just
buying products and somehow that got me
from one task to the next
and then I
actually think I have it  I usually
did it quite sensibly, but
I also always did a lot. I also mixed Märklin,
I think that was one of the biggest
learning curves, next to when we
started Obi next, I was also
responsible for the country of
Austria and in Austria  we have a
market share of 35 percent, around 700
million euros in sales and shortly
before that we had a
bauMax that was a local player that
didn't make it then we
took over many branches, 40 of them
and a year after this integration
I took over the country  and
then I was actually
jointly responsible for the markets operationally and that was
also a super great learning curve because that’s where
our access to the customer is, that’s where
our goods are, that’s where our
markets are, that’s the customer contact and
absurd moment, I imagine  before when
you run a hardware store like this,
many strange things happen
or you wonder Werder everything that
buys or you there in any case you
face a series of weaknesses in experience that you ca
n’t actually imagine as normal people
and if they have to  expected here
yes I don't even know if I'm there yes so
I think I have another
anecdote that I think I
find more appropriate namely when I
started there now had to know in
such a hardware store sales there's
a lot about were placement so  there are
always in the middle aisle the
pallets of white color and then they
are moved from right to left,
then the sun comes out and then
you push the flowers from the entrance and
so you simply act with the real
and when I visit my first market
in Austria you have to
say that I didn't have the training that
I know which one was going where
and then I went to Mark
and I just listened to the employees
and asked them what was
going on, what the customers wanted and
uh  I noticed that I
came across as such an alien I
asked completely different questions and
then I left they I had finished
visiting the market they were so
irritated that I didn't really
shifted from right to left  like that
is actually so typical and I
think you saw quite clearly
what happens in a DIY store every day,
how closely you are just working on it
and are constantly on the move and
are always chatting and tackling and
that is also significant  uplift so if
you then put the flowers outside
then you'll immediately notice that more I
'd rather say you'll notice immediately if
you don't do that can exhaust fan
so that you have that kind of a loss
so it's okay we already have so
the weather is playing one  huge role if
if you start well the earlier in
March the sun comes out then there is
an immediate lift because if it is too hot that
nothing grows then you don't sell any
more lawn then you maybe sell
irrigation and of course that also makes
inventory management really challenging
a lot depends on seasonality
too there are still
innovations now independent of the
digital i.e. app or website things
that are obvious that you
were doing a lot there that’s also
obvious but there are so many new
categories it wasn’t there before so
buy  now with you people
solar systems to which yourself or
are there any other
innovations products new markets new
concepts this is the area that would
want to get into so I believe that if
you look at the homes and
gardens of customers not just from one
sales channel  DIY store looks
but from an end customer point of view
and says the customer lives in
his home in his garden what does
he do and then that's
exactly what you mentioned also
how will my car at home be more sustainable
how do I use less energy the
housing stock in Germany  more than 60
percent were built before 1949, so it's
really old and that's why you have
a renovation backlog and
then new markets open up, but you
probably don't all work on them in the same way
as the classic DIY store
came into being, you buy an item
and put it on the shelf the customer  comes drags
out and so takes with you
the topics you mentioned,
whether that's making a home smarter,
whether that's the photovoltaic system
on the roof, whether that's somehow the
irrigation system for your garden,
these are all things that are a bit
more complex and  which are no longer just
a product, but already a
product and a product and an
implementation, so they tend to think about solutions
and that is definitely the
growth area that we see because
the market is actually 20 billion euros in size
for the construction market in Germany
but if you look at the homes and gardens of
our customers, the market will be
10 times as big 200 billion
and if you then ask the customers yes
and who could be a partner
for your photovoltaic on the roof then
you don't have a brand today you have  yes,
no suppliers and then the
customers like to think a Obi because
we have been present
in their homes for many years and that is also
definitely the area in which we where we
say we also have
future markets, so that means that too
more service with new products
and even if a different
personnel structure, but I mean that
nobody can install a photovoltaic system there
and the customer
cannot absolutely do that himself and and
there again I think we have
shown the franchise partners
that you work together with partners
maybe they can then locally
do one or the other better than we can
and you can imagine that for other
services and service is
also so if I
was here from the while Mario from
Empire or Philipp from 1,  5 degrees so these
are the people who
have TANs yes we also have we are also in
contact and then we
talked yes well okay to
think about it in concrete terms is somehow
a partnership in terms of sales okay
know a look at quickcommerce so
I saw it  there was now in our
project that you also
want to deliver in a gorilla-like way, so you have them in Hamburg,
so in any case, I thought it would be
better to do something with a parking lot
than to
try it myself, yes, I think those are things
we say  we have an
innovation unit with obi with
squared where we understand exactly such topics
where we where we
enter into venture partnerships in order to then
understand how things work and
I think we
understand quickform what I think you can do with the use case quite well
describe it well is
on a construction site just have to
do it and then the tube is
empty or that's exactly what was missing and then
you want it there quickly that's
what a relevant use case is and
um that's why we
started it and us  to understand but
not yet so that we say
we have to get in tomorrow and
do it ourselves okay but you are
probably with this delivery service
are really very broken yes
so we need our capital for
our technological conversion we have
a lot planned  and we are looking for a lot of people
and also invest a lot and those are
the things where we and then we have to
invest in our markets so that
they stay fresh so we have many
other fields of investment that's why
quick Commerce now
invests additionally because
sometimes
you can now too
I noticed such moments of communication
around fireworks, so
at some point you
very consciously communicated that in your
markets, at least where he
can decide for himself, no longer
sells fireworks, so always up-to-date, the
franchise partners sometimes
did it anyway, I think, or
decided differently, how come  something
that we decide that we are
not, so we are there are a
few things I mean the discussion about
fireworks, you did,
everyone noticed them and about the effect
of fireworks on our
environment and accordingly we as Obi  we
also have a social
obligation in which I would say 95%
brand awareness, we also have
a social obligation and we
want to fulfill that and
with the fireworks it was easy for us
to say in the argument
that we want to do without it but  who
would have and did you earn money in the end,
yes, with that you have already
made sales with it and uh absolutely
and that is then an entrepreneurial
decision to forgo it and
that is a bit that someone has the
idea and carries it with you  before and then
you say yes, there are certain things that
you, I mean, we also
left the supplement and that is the
handout that we
distributed, we printed millions of pieces of paper
and threw them in the letter yesterday
and always ended up in the trash can for a short time
Such an insert has an
opening rate of less than ten
percent, and those who don't refuse
advertising are
easy, and we made a conscious
decision not to do so in the summer.
That's also an
activation impulse that you
then lose  And we
also did that for reasons of
sustainability and of course also
for marketing
effectiveness customers, but
the issue of sustainability was also
an issue for us, which means you can
already see a wide variety of places where you
ask yourselves that we don't have to position our company in a more
contemporary way
I don't think we're there at all,
we still have a long way to go,
but we're also setting ourselves the task
and how it's going to be communicated to the
franchise partners who say
we see it differently, we still want to
sell it because for  this is
hard cash when in doubt and
I wanted to give that up, so
of course we try to
explain our reasoning to the franchise partner and
the majority of the franchise partners are
also involved, so I think these
are always isolated cases, which of course
somehow  then still
get my greater attention
but the majority of the fanshospartner is
there too with the ways and
but in the end they are also
independent entrepreneurs and that is
also an advantage in many places
and of course it would be nicer if everyone then followed this this
this logic  follows, but yes,
in the end, as I said,
you will also be self-employed, you we have to
worry about the next few months or
years, so with you now,
maybe a lot of consumption has been brought forward,
so to speak, all the hardware store purchases of the
last few years that
have already taken place and in  The future
will be a little less as a result and
then the recession, which is
somehow hanging over us, so it's coming
that had years ahead of you,
yes, well, at least I'm alone,
I don't even know how far ahead I'm
thinking, but the year 2023 alone
is  not that the best year
in which everything comes together like you
just said comes out of wood from the
Corona PI I think everyone has
bought their second grill and has
already spent one or the other holiday
at home and maybe has now
more likely to want
to go on vacation somewhere else again, if
the wallet allows it at all, because now,
as you say, uh, there is also
inflation and the buying
restraint and
of course we play that too, so I think there are
now they are more like that
[music  ]
less
attractive months that are ahead of us
and it is all the more important that
we continue with our change process in such a phase
and do not stop because it
also shows how markets are
changing again, how demand behavior is
changing and  then we have to
be there accordingly
stay close to our customers how many customers is
independent of the app do you have a
normal month so for fun
you have four million you might have about the app a
year but yeah it's
difficult for you for me  to
answer like that because we, uh, because we uh,
as I said,
cannot measure any customers one-to-one, so the
customer buys anonymously when
shopping at an OBI store, but we have
over 10 million customers who buy from us
a year or something in between
That will be 10 and 15 million and
we have over 100 million
tickets that was sold or on the
website in Germany we have over
250 million visitas so it's quite
a lot this one there is also quite good
what's happening in society
so you notice certain
changes where you say that is
actually still not communicated enough,
for example a few weeks ago
i was at an event the
boss of Rewe said that he
can already feel very strongly that people are now
going to discounts much more that is  That
was also the case for me, for example, so
we'll see that too, then we'll see if
you use Idealo price search engines, if that's
where the traffic comes from or other
things like that, we'll see if
people start
buying instead of buying brands, we'll
see if  the customers start when crises like this
arise, then they go ahead
and consult each other. Power generators
were then bought quite a lot because he
says who knows if there will be a major
power outage and so on
and so on, you can see the centiment
quite well in there, but we  we
also regularly ask our customers
about their centiment because that’s just what you
are as a retailer then it had to
be your turn to understand that we
will be busy for the next few months with
customers and
two or three years ago it was about
making the home beautiful and now  It's about
making them more efficient
or maybe not even calling a craftsman
but repairing things yourself
because the craftsman
is expensive, relatively expensive or
is also fully booked and then you tend to do
the repairs yourself again.
We see something like that relatively
The rate of preppers in
Germany quickly rose sharply, as there were
already amazing sales to change,
so the whole subject of gas, then
gas bottles, then also the subject of
power generators, yes, or now
something too, if in Hamburg, for example, where we
are here, also just completely  The
whole topic of mold is extreme because now there is not
as much ventilation to
keep the temperature in the house you
suddenly have a lot more mold infestation and
uh you see that then yes and then
when there is mold you have to
paint the wall again afterwards and and  so
on and so forth awesome that's
amazing that you do that immediately then
this yes I wish we
could actually use it even better for
communication again to lead the customers
even better then if we
recognize such things we still have to do
a bit  get better because you
actually see things, you understand
them and then translate them for the customer,
also for those who do
n't take action themselves, but for whom you
can somehow address it, I think we can
actually do that better, there
is  any brands or
any retail concepts that
want to particularly impress you that they
do it really well
in this online offline world that you
somehow look at more and more
obviously something that
you find inspiring somehow because
you're not from USA Walmart or there's
somehow that they do the good thing that
you look at them intensely there
are always elements like that,
for example what I find very good in element what I find
like the Apple in
its store with which to have advice at
a certain point and
I've always found it impressive at Apple to be there with absolute customer orientation,
and when you
see the OBI store with our 10,000
square meters, we
won't be able to do that in terms of width, but
maybe we'll manage to
achieve this quality in certain places  and
then also for the customer the understanding
at this place you will always be helped
you will always be advised because you are always
fighting against this image in the hardware store
you will not find any sales person and
and they will not help and we
also know from our analyzes
how much  of satisfied customers leave the hardware store
and how many satisfied
customers are with Obi when they have
been advised and our employees are in contact
so when you are in contact with the employee
it is a huge asset
and how we can do it even better
I think that's where I am  I'm always looking
for inspiration,
yes, I think this whole topic of
customer lifetime value can be looked at very well, especially
with the
clothing
retailers, so
sell about us or then in Zalando,
I think they don't do it as
badly as their offers do
Customer lifetime value can
also be aligned there always quite well Inspiration sometimes
measures
okay okay there is an angel the
exchange with the owners at
Tengelmann that’s also a lot of
dynamism for me in the last few years you’ve been
there longer yes of course it’s one
of ours  That is why there
is a close exchange and there
is also a good exchange. The basic strategic direction is there
Sometimes, as you
just described, in such a
recession the sales are
no longer so bubbling that you still
stick to the strategy, which is why
exchange is important
at OBI or traditionally in office for a very long time,
so your predecessor was how many
years my predecessor was there  20 years there, yes,
that means you have
already been mentally prepared for the next 20 years,
well, I haven't, so I've prepared myself
for a little less now,
I think that's what's
so strong in these times
I really do
n't know if that's still possible,
so if we in what will
the economy look like in 20 years and
how will trade and
technology look like I think you have to
always staying very close to the ravages of
time that's why I do
n't want to think that's enough for me if I
now
implement our strategy well and
are successful with the customer and
achieve our goals I think in the
back of five years okay
five-year contracts three so
yes there are management board contracts  always like that
between 53 years okay but that
just means that someone
obviously believed that there were colleagues
doing yes
that's probably the way it is, we
also had a process where I
had talks with both the many Tengelmann and the other minority shareholders and  about the future orientation
of Obi how do I
imagine the business model change but also the
organizational and cultural change and
that was one perspective and the
other perspective was that
I actually
went through a kind of assessment center there, so
it will be fine  accompanied professionally
although I was known, but I think or maybe
not, although
I was simply
accompanied professionally, I think that with a job like that,
it’s also appropriate
You can also see him later on Instagram,
but LinkedIn in a pop of
orange sweaters and somehow sweaters
appeared when you spoke to me for the first time
and it wasn't that common before, so I'm
also consciously trying
to change the culture, yes,
I'm just consciously trying to be
open and
I think we don't care whether it's the store
employees in the OBI store
or the colleagues
who started the training
or our data
engineers and third parties, yes, we're
looking for them in Cologne and we got married,
we follow everyone  a big
vision and and a mission and and
we have to bring everyone
together
[music]
now yes but what do I mean
everyone who wants to continue sitting can also
sit but I have already
introduced that you can yes I can  everyone
uses it and I take that from everyone
to use unless they tell me
no better if they but it has
n’t happened before okay okay and
then we all have to
gather behind it and I think that’s why it’s there
too and more orange  Poly I
think we distributed it to everyone
that is also a
signal so we all have a lot of fun for the Obi brand
with a direction a strategy leading to the
future,
so in terms of sales
it has already reached a relatively high level,
so what consolation are you there  more on so
what what will say well I as I said
I was in this in this
five-year rhythm and we
definitely want to get over the ten
okay that's already a word so
right now with the early
consumption and so maybe there  you have to come up with a
few new ideas we have
five years so it's not in the
year 23 okay we'll definitely do that
where you last question maybe
it's actually the obi from the
French from the French
word hobby uh in my stand  was or
so that is also my knowledge yes so
obi so from obi
but are brilliant name three letters
orange the beaver you could have been a
marketing expert
was me someone thought obi obi
somehow and then you took yes that's how
it's told so i  I also
talked to Mr. Mouse about it
that seems to be alive so quickly he
's still alive I also
met him in my er sort of my at the
start I met him for
lunch and he's
an inspiring personality too
so comes strong from values ​​and uh
should sell someone like that no yes he
is out but in he is
still
traveled is actually
still in his old age Germany
and and tells different
is invited as a guest speaker and
yes brings to  he'll pass on his values ​​and his
views,
okay,
well, I'm curious to see what's happening in Obi
in the hardware store segment, such an
innovation might actually be there next year,
the
photovoltaic systems or something similar, so
thank you very much for coming around, good luck
now in the  new role is
still somehow many many years ahead of you
um and then above all until May
when you are there and we're looking forward to
seeing you at the festival, so oBI is there,
so to speak, present with us um and there
's also something new for us  is in the
mood for it so in that sense yes we are
also in the mood for it looking forward to it it said and
we will also
show our products a bit and that we
can offer for our business
partners are also looking forward to it so who
Burger Obi will come by in May
then there's not only to be touchable to be
touchable a small
market almost the market now
but a small stand maybe
a beaver exactly maybe orange
jumper perfect in the sense thank you thank you
[music]